all right we're just recording because
now we're just overthinking it and when
we overthink it yeah that's what happens
no hi my name is very snobby I don't
know now you know your life is different
now and it's been a second since I've
done a favorites video in fact hundreds
of thousands of seconds days weeks
months even I wanted to talk about some
of the things that I liked more than
other things currently at the moment
I've decided that the more appropriate
term for these items instead of like
monthly favorites it's coz items are not
my favorite things but they are special
today we show you my std's all of it
just for that moment you know what it's
worth it is my microphone turned ah yeah
you know what you're an STD I would even
go so far as to call you a UTI utility
thankful for I am nope here we go first
this is needles no more no more whoa
that's what it's called hmm I don't pay
attention to the things that I put on in
and around my person no more baggage ID
puffing gel from dr. brand my friend
Jocelyn Q's that you guys might know
it's amazing comedian writer DIY funny
lady extraordinaire I'll link all of her
stuff below she posted about this on her
Instagram story and I messaged her and I
was like I need a new under-eye conceal
their baggage deep Hufford situates I
have little tiny car accidents the
airbags explode and I need something
that puts them back in that is a needles
or any sort of cosmetic surgery and she
was like this is awesome I love it it's
a little expensive but I got it on
sephora.com and I love it it stings and
if you know me you know I love a good
sting
dream your bags away oh my god I haven't
had any major complications so that's a
sign that this is an STD yeah next okay
yeah yeah see ya this is a scent I
bought off of the Internet
that's right I bought it without
smelling it opposite of how you should
buy a car or a baby or food this is a
scent from Zara it's called black amber
I like musky kind of unisexual sense I
don't like floral soapy scents you guys
know I soap and I don't get along a good
thing you can't smell through your
screen right now because it musky under
there I've been wearing like the same
roll-on Elizabeth and James Nirvana
black and Nirvana white for like the
last couple years and I haven't found
something that is of that same sort of
scent quality to me and so I took a risk
I did a whole big Zara purchase and I
added this to my cart because black
amber I know it's black amber not amber
alright my South Philly A's are getting
in the way there's no way that black
amber is gonna smell like hibiscus tea
Pomplamoose foamy vanilla that
everything else to me smells like and
you know what it smells better than I
could have anticipated it smells great
feels like um like like if like it like
if you know the it's like if you took
damn it's like if you took it's like if
you took firewood and you queer I ditch
a little bit that's what this smells
like
look if mosque was wearing high heels I
mean it's our black amber cute yes yeah
yes is a product that I have not been
recommended that I didn't seek out
intentionally that just fell in my lap
when I was doing a drunk Amazon Prime
now order I decided to look up tinted
moisturizer cuz I love to use that under
my foundation maybe cuz I like that
heavy coverage
I like layers I like putting up walls
emotionally and foundationally and this
came up it's called elta MD skincare UV
physical broad-spectrum lightly tinted
chemical free active ingredients
oil-free with antioxidants transparent
and zinc oxide UVA UVB protection water
resistant facial sunscreen
and you get something lower maintenance
than that I thought it was attention
moisturizer so it turns out it's a
tinted sunscreen which is even better so
now I'm by accident protecting my skin
more than I thought I was it's extra
sensitive and post-procedure skin don't
know what that means so if that means
anything to you it says it on this tube
and it's three ounces so I can travel
with this in my carry-on like a tinted
sunscreen which I didn't know existed
until I actually read this before I shot
this video it's light enough that you
can wear this by itself if you're
someone that likes lightweight coverage
like tinted moisturizer a type of result
region like I do put it under your own
foundation I'm wearing it under my
foundation today can you tell the Sun
can cuz it can't get sniped ultraviolet
more like ultraviolent let yourself out
cuz you know welcome here either way I
like this cute next yes yeah yeah yeah
the mayor and I recently went down to
South by Southwest is patreon invited us
down thank you very much patreon we did
a live podcast down there which you can
listen to a link in the description box
below
but patreon being the wonderful gracious
host of us that they were they sent us
off with a bunch of goodies and a bunch
of the goodies that they gave us we're
from this company called saj si je which
I've never heard of before
all these essential oils they gave us
like regular sized ones and then they
gave us this little what's called a
pocket pharmacy it was just cute as heck
all these little roll-on essential oil
things and each one is different this
one's fortified which is a cough
suppressant which is I've been using
that crazy on my throat because I've
been sick since I was down in South by
because I don't know my limits even
though everything I'm presenting to you
seems like if you saw it on paper it
would be recommended from someone that
has their life together
mmm should also be called grace presents
items that make her seem
overcompensating we put together or my
CDs oh no I mean two sides of the same
coin
then there's pain release this is a
blend for like stiff joints and muscles
this one's my favorite
it's the peppermint halo a cooling and
soothing oil blend for the head and you
roll it over your forehead and like
temples this Stu up in the best way
possible
I love this so much it's crazy I tried
this for the first time just like kind
of non
threw it on and then like went about my
day like cleaning up my house and Ulsan
I was like what is happening to my head
and my temples and I feel great and
crazy and wonderful everything is
delightful I'm firing on all sensory
cylinders right now then there's gutsy
which is a soothing belly massage blend
I haven't tried that yet he stress
relief soothing oil' blend because I got
this for free I didn't know if this was
like a really high-end brand I went onto
their website and you can get this kit
for 60 bucks that has all of the travel
size essential oils you can also buy
them independently if there's one that
you like more than others also set um
chap sticks like this is a sweet fennel
lip balm Who am I I know garden meets
Gwyneth Paltrow this is also like a kind
of [ __ ] rad gift to give to anyone
Mother's Day present Father's Day
present this is a really unisexual item
I'm just putting it out there I'm
helping you help you is that my new
tagline no that's just what I should say
to myself in the mirror every morning
Thank You patreon by the way go check
out our patreon for this make it weird
patron commish let's make it weird you
can see it well I just showed it to you
a basic [ __ ] I'm not afraid to admit it
I'm a Jersey girl on ironically
continues to live her life in uggs and
leggings and I finally made the jump I
was at HomeGoods looking for dumb art
and I stumbled upon something I didn't
even know existed
um bedding the Australian not so
attractive both fully functionally and
what only comfortable and forever my
favourite boot brand hug makes bedding
and it was $60 at HomeGoods and I bought
it and me directly it is the most
comfortable comforter and pillow set
I've ever experienced in my entire life
I feel like what baby kangaroos must
feel like inside the little pouch the
furry warm comfortable pouch of their
mama kangaroo I feel like a marsupial
and I have never slept better I've no
wonder those kangaroos in a box all the
time is because they they're they're
well rested and upset the
people don't understand how comfortable
the innards of their reproduction pouch
are alright I think that's it let me
know if you guys like favourites videos
if you do give it a thumbs up and let me
know in the comments down below I really
want you guys to tell me about your STDs
so leave that also in the comments down
below don't forget to subscribe to this
YouTube channel because I post videos
and make sure you go listen to not too
deep my podcast that comes out every
Monday the video versions go up here on
this YouTube channel it's the most
consistent thing that I'm part of you
can also listen to it everywhere you
listen to podcast and awesome aimer and
i have a podcast called this make it
weird they can listen to you everywhere
that you listen to podcast and also we
upload our video version of that on that
this might get YouTube channel all of
the links are down below there's so much
in my cooter for you guys to check out I
don't know
great really great what's ours